in this episode we'll go over the fifth
lab in the GCP essentials quest
hello node kubernetes you can take this
lab on quick laps without needing to
take the previous ones but after
completing all the laps in this quest
you will get this fancy badge right here
not to mention bragging rights so let's
get right to it kubernetes is an open
source system for automating deployment
scaling and management of containerized
applications it can run on many
different environments from laptops to
high availability multi node clusters
from public clouds to on-premise
deployments from virtual machines to
bare metal it groups containers that
make up an application into logical
units for easy management and discovery
kubernetes builds upon fifteen years of
experience of running production
workloads at Google combined with Best
of Breed ideas and practices from the
community the goal of this hands-on lab
is free to turn code that you have
developed into a triplicate adapt
ocation running on kubernetes which is
running on kubernetes engine for this
lab the code will be a simple hello
world nodejs app here's a diagram of the
various parts and play in this lab to
help you understand how the pieces fit
together with one another use this as a
reference as you progress through the
lab it should all make sense by the time
you get to the end this lab will take
about an hour to complete and you'll
create a node that j/s server a docker
file that describes the image you want
to build a container cluster then a
kubernetes pod and then scale up your
services in case you suddenly need more
capacity for your application the lab
only scratches the surface of this
technology and we encourage you to
explore further with your own pods
replication controllers and services if
you've been following these videos and
completing these quick laps in order
you're almost almost done with this
quest only two more laps to go and the
next one is stackdriver QuickStart
you